la position c'est pas comme ça c'était
une première pour la plupart de ces
enfants de 7 à 15 ans venus des
l'encours de trappes ou encore de
guyancourt s'essayer au bmx vaincre
peut-être une peur et vibrer au rythme
des bosses une initiation d'abord en
douceur avant de tester pour les plus
téméraires la piste olympique qui
accueillera l'entraînement des athlètes
pendant les jo 2024 en fait on a renaat
comme des traces ligne blanche on a
essayé par centre- avec le guide au
doigt tourné comme des zigzags on va
réussir le mieux
alors on fait des bosses enfin essayer
de faire des bosses et trous avec le
vélo pourront s'entraîner quoi pour bat
pour si on veut venir des professionnels
il fallait vraiment prendre beaucoup de
mails ans après je pense que ça va y
aller et à mais c'était vraiment cool
parce que ça faisait une petite
sensation
il y en a qui ont un petit peu de
difficulté à se mettre debout déjà juste
de synchroniser le pédalage et de voir
jusqu'où ils peuvent aller pour pour
franchir à une bosse correctement sans
sans danger après le bmx les jeunes
yvelinois ont visité le vélodrome
nationale une journée découverte du site
olympique pour faciliter l'accès au
sport moyen d'expression et vecteur de
lien social pour le secours populaire
des yvelines
c'est primordial de rendre ici le sport
pour pouvoir faire en sorte que les
enfants et les familles puisse s'évader
du quotidien et qu'ils puissent
découvrir 10 sport
qui n'ont pas forcément l'habitude
degretre dans l'après midi les enfants
ont pu rencontrer le champion français
de bmx romain racines avant d'assister à
un entraînement une journée qu'ils ne
sont pas prêts d'oublier